واحده من اكبر الكوارث العالميه بهذه
الكلمات وسط الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان كارثه الزلزال التي ضربت جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا وفي اخر احصائيات
الضحايا في تركيا قد بلغت
359 قتيلا فيما تجاوز عدد الجرحى اثنين
وعشرين
الفريحا اردوغان اعلن خلال كلمه له قبل
ساعه قليله حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاثه اشهر
في المناطق المتضرره بالزلزال والى سوريا
الجاره التي سجلت حتى الان
1621 قتيلا نتيجه الزلزال الممتد من
الاراضي التركيه
هذا الزلزال يعد من اكبر الكوارث الطبيعيه
في التاريخ ومختلف القوى الامنيه
والعسكريه تشارك في عمليات الانقاذ لكن
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه هذه العمليات خصصنا اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار لعمليات الانقاذ وندعو كل
الدول لمساعدتنا بالمعدات اللازمه بغض
النظر عن الوضع السياسي وهناك 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده في البحث والانقاذ كذلك
هناك طائرات مسيره تشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ وتم انشاء اربعه وخمسين الف موقع
للايواء في مناطق الزلزال وهناك خطه لفتح
فنادق انطاليا امام المتضررين ونعلن حاله
الطوارئ في المناطق المتضرره التي ستستمر
لمده ثلاثه اشهر كما ان هناك عشر مدن
اعلنت كمناطق كوارث
وقد انتشرت مقاطع مصوره للمسيرات فوق
منطقه هاتاي التركيه التي تعرضت للضرر
الاكبر بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
وتسبب حتى الان في مقتل 872 شخصا في
الولايه بالاضافه الى الضرر المادي الكبير
الذي طال العديد من المباني
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول منفد العربيه غسان
مرحبا بك ضعنا في اخر التطورات اولا ما هي
اخر المعلومات المتوفره
حول عمليات الانقاذ الارقام للضحايا
والمصابين
نعم بالفعل خالد قبل قليل قبل ساعه من
الان تقريبا كان هناك كلمه للرئيس تركيا
رجب طيب اردوغان وقال ان عدد القتل ارتفع
الى
3549 قتيلا وعدد المصابين ارتفع الى اكثر
من 22 الف مصاب وقال انه تم انقاذ ما يزيد
عن ثمان الاف شخص وان عمليات الانقاذ
والاجلاء ما زالت متواصله حتى الساعه
ومستمره بشكل حثيث وكبير جدا كان يعني
اردوغان واضحا في كلامه بان الكارثه كارثه
كبيره جدا وهي غير مسبوقه
وبان زلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه لا بثيله له
في العالم نقلا عن خبراء زلازل كما قال
اردوغان وبالتالي حجم الكارثه كبير جدا
وايضا اشار الى ان هذه
اعداد اعداد القتلى والمصابين سترتفع
وسترتفع بشكل كبير خلال الساعات المقبله
وربما الايام المقبله على اي حال اكد بان
عمليات المساعده وتقديم الاغاثه
والاخلاق والانقاذ مستمره حتى هذه الساعه
رغم التحديات والصعوبات التي تواجه فرق
الانقاذ سواء كان من الظروف الجويه
القاسيه والعاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب
البلاد او من ناحيه
الوضع الذي تشهده المنطقه من هزات
ارتداديه سلطات تحدثت عن اكثر من 300 هزه
ارتداديه منذ امس حتى هذا اليوم وبالتالي
هناك مخاوف كبيره من السلطات بان توقع هذه
الهزات مزيد من الانهيارات وبالتالي مزيد
من القتلى والمصابين بين المواطنين في تلك
المنطقه خصوصا ان بعض هذه اله وصلت الى
درجه 54 درجات على مقياس وهي بالتالي تشكل
خطوره كبيره على المباني وعلى المواطنين
وسلطات تدعو المواطنين والمنكوبين
والمدنيين بعدم العوده الى البيوت
والمنازل والمباني حتى وان كانت تضررت
بشكل بسيط جدا لان ذلك يشكل خطر كبير على
حياتهم في حال وقوع الهزات الارتداديه
وربما تنهار في اي لحظه ما يعقد من مساعي
السلطات في عمليات الانقاذ التي تتعامل
حتى اللحظه بشكل رسمي كما اعلنت وبحسب
الارقام الرسميه مع
5,700 مبنى ومنزل منهار وربما العدد ايضا
يرتفع
بشكل كبير هناك يعني معلومات غير رسميه
تشير بان ربما يكون عدد المباني المنهاره
اكبر من ذلك بكثير هناك فرق انقاذ يعني
حكوميه تتالف من عشرين الف مشارك وايضا
هناك
ايضا المساعده دوليه التي تصل تباعا الى
تركيا سعودي اليك للوقوف على اخر ايضا
المعلومات قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
عدد المتضررين بالزلزال الذي اودى بحياه
الالاف في تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى 23
مليون كما اشرت المنظمه الى ان نحو خمسه
ملايين منهم هم في حاله ضعف واكدت ان
عمليه ايصال المساعدات عبر الحدود الى
سوريا غربيه او الى شمال غرب سوريا من
المرجح ان تواجه صعوبات بسبب الاضرار التي
سببها الزلزال
ايضا المتحدثه باسم الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه بان تدفق مساعدات المنظمه
المهمه من تركيا الى شمال غرب سوريا توقف
مؤقتا بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت بالطرق الى
جانب مشكلات لوجستيه اخرى مرتبطه بتداعيات
الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب البلدين واكدت
المتحدثه بان بعض الطرق معطله وان البعض
الاخر لا يمكن الوصول اليه انضم الينا من
القامشلي مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه
ضعنا في اخر التطورات والتحديثات
وسير عمليات الانقاذ في المناطق السوريه
المنكوبه
لا تزال فرق الدفاع المدني في مناطق
المعارضه تواصل اعملها مع هطول امطار في
بعض البلدات والاقضيه
والقرى يعني عمليات انتشال يعني جثث يعني
مستمره هناك جثه جديده منذ صباح اليوم حتى
الان تم انتشالها من مناطق المعارضه بعضها
ارسل الى يعني الى المشافي وبعضها تم يعني
استقبالها من قبل الاهالي مباشره مناطق
يعني المعارضه خاصه سرمدا وجنديرس
والاتارب شهدت اليوم يعني دفن اكثر من 600
شخص يعني مراسم دفن 600 من ضحايا هذا
الزلزال فيما لا يزال عدد كبير من الجثث
في المشافي يحاول الاهالي التعرف عليهم
هناك يعني عوائل كامله قتلت في هذا
الزلزال لم يبقى لديهم من يقوم بع دفنه
وبالتالي يعني لا تزال جثث هؤلاء موجوده
في
المشافي اما من طرف النظام السوري يبدو ان
عمليات يعني ازاله الانقراض والبحث عن
الناجين وانتشار الجثث من تحت الانقاذ على
نهايتها تحديدا في مدينه اللاذقيه التي
يعني شهدت جهود جباره من قبل يعني الدفاع
المدني وبلديه المدينه والهلال الاحمر
السوري اضافه الى مشاركين من القوات
الروسيه وايضا متخصصين من الجزائر وايضا
من لبنان وصلوا الى هذه المدينه وشاركوا
في عمليات ارتشال الجثث يعني العدد العدد
الوفيات في تغيير طفيف كان العدد
6120 لربما حاليا نتحدث عن
6123 اي بي زياده ثلاث اشخاص على عدد
الوفيات في عموم المناطق السوريه
الوضع في المخيمات الجمعه هل يختلف وباي
صوره عن المناطق الاخرى التي دمرت مبانيها
نحن نتحدث عن سكان
النازحين يعني معظم السكان في مناطق
المعارضه هم نازحين من ارياف دمشق ارياف
حلب الياف مدينه حماه مدينه حمص والمدينه
نفسها فبالتالي يعني هذه الكارثه جاءت
تعقد ظروف الماذومه اصلا وتضيف عليهم
اعداء يعني
اضافيه غير محتمله بحقيقه الامر وبالتالي
يعني
يمكن ان نتحدث بان هناك حاليا في مناطق
يعني المعارضه اكثر من مليون نازع خرجوا
من بيوتهم سواء اولئك الذين تضرط منازلهم
بشكل مباشر او سويت بالارض او بشكل جزئي
وايضا الذين يخافون البقاء في في منطقه
الكارثه قتلوا الخروج من المنازل باتجاه
الارياف الساحات الفارغه بعض المياه في
السيارات بعضهم عند الاهل والاق الاصدقاء
والبعض في يعني الملاعب المغلقه وصلاه
الافراح واحيانا يعني المطاعم التي يعني
بعض اصحابها فتحوا الابواب ومن نزحوا من
المنازل
غسان شكرا جزيلا لك سنعود اليك في ثنائية
هذه عفوا جمعه عكاش من القامشلي شكرا
جزيلا لك حتى الان سنعود لك في ثنايا هذه
التغطيه
[موسيقى]
نعود الى اسطنبول الان الى المفرد العربيه
من هناك غسان ابو لوز غسان الرئيس التركي
كان في خطابه يتحدث ايضا عن تحركات من كل
الجهات لتقديم المساعده للمناطق المنكوبه
والمتضررين الجرائز زلزال الى اي مدى
استطاعت هذه الفرق الوصول الى المناطق
المنكوبه وما هي اكثر هذه المناطق ضررا
حتى
فقط اود الاشاره بدايه الى ما تتناقله
وسائل اعلام محليه تركيه عن وزيره تجاره
تركيا اذ يقول انه لم يتبقى احد من
المواطنين تحت الانقاض في ولايه كلس
والحياه في الولايه تبدا بالعوده لطبيعتها
شيئا في شيئا هذه احدى الولايات التي
تعرضت للزلزال ويؤكد بانه لا يوجد احد تحت
الانقاذ وان الحياه هناك تعود شيئا في
شيئا الى طبيعتها طبيعتها في تلك الولايه
بالنسبه لسؤالك خالد بالعوده للمساعدات ما
زالت يعني مستمره ومتواصله
لتلك المناطق المنكوبه تحديدا هاتاي او
كرما كرما كمرهان وايضا المناطق الجنوبيه
التي تعرضت للزلزال وهي مركز الزلزال التي
تعرضت لتلك الهزات القويه والاكثر
الكاذبه وهو ما تطرق اليه ايضا اردوغان في
كلمته قبل قليل وبالتالي هناك تحذيرات من
تلك الاشاعات والاخبار
المضلله وايضا هناك
يعني تحذير لهؤلاء بالمحاسبه والملاحقه
القانونيه لما يمكن ان يتشكل هذه الاشاعات
من حاله من الفوضى والهلع بين المواطنين
خصوصا بعض الرسائل التي تنتشر على وصل
الاجتماعي وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مثل
واتساب وغيرها
تشير بان هناك مثلا زلازل ربما تقع في
الساعه الفلانيه او ربما يحدث هزات
ارتداديه قويه وعنيفه وما يثير الهلع بين
المواطنين وحاله ارتباك بين المواطنين
والمدنيين وايضا السلطات في التعامل مع
مثل هذه الظروف الاستثنائيه التي تمر فيها
البلاد والتي تحاول مسابقه
الزمن
لمساعده
المنكوبين وايضا انقاذ
عالقين تحت الانقاض في المناطق المنكوبه
خالد ما هي اهم الطرق التي تعرضت للدمار
هذا الزلزال وكيف يتم التعامل مع هل هناك
فرق في حجم الضرر ايضا بين طريق واخر هل
هناك ممرات بديله تم استحداثها بعد هذا
الزلزال
خالد هو ما تسعى اليه السلطات التركيه
استحداث طرق بديله خصوصا في تلك التي
تعرضت الى ضرر لا تحضرني اسماء الطرق
حاليا خالد لكن تتعامل السلطات التركيه مع
هذه الحاله الاستثنائيه وهذه الكارثه التي
ضربت المناطق الجنوبيه وبالتالي هناك
بالفعل سيناريوهات لطرق بديله وايضا هناك
مشاركه للجيش التركي وجسر جوي لجيش التركي
هناك طوافات عسكريه تقوم بعمليات نقل
واخلاء للمصابين والجرحى من المناطق
المنكوبه الى ولايات اخرى والى مستشفيات
اخرى لمعالجه هؤلاء المصابين في تلك
المناطق البعيده عن المناطق المتضرره في
مثلا في غازي عنتاب او في اتاي او غيرها
وبالتالي العمليات ما زالت مستمره وهناك
يعني
جهود مستمره لفتح طرق بديله لايصال
الامدادات والمساعدات من جهه والاخلاء من
جهه اخرى وبالتالي هذا التحدي او هذه
الدائره التي يعني تمر فيها
حاله الانقاذ وعمليه
الاخلاء الاخلاء من جهه
وانقاذ من جهه اخرى وبالتالي هذا تحدي
ايضا السلطات التركيه سواء من ناحيه ان
كان هناك طرق تعرضت للدمار وبالبحث عن طرق
بديله او من ناحيه
الظروف الجويه والثلوج المتساقطه وربما
تؤدي الى اغلاق بعض الطرق لكن تحاول
السلطات ايضا للعمل ساعه بساعه ولحظه
بلحظه على فتح هذه الطرق ومواصل التامين
المناطق المنكوبه بفرق الانقاذ والمساعدات
الانسانيه التي يحتاجها المنكوبين تحدث عن
السلطات تتحدث عن اكثر من 50 الف تم
ايوائهم في عدد من المدن ما زالت العمليات
مستمره
لاحتواء وايواء هؤلاء المنكوبين في تلك
المناطق وبالتالي يتم اللجوء الى المدارس
والصلاه الرياضيه والخيام لكن الحاجات
كبيره
والمساعدات
يعني بحاجه الى ان تكون اكبر من ذلك نتيجه
الاعداد الكبيره المتضرره من المواطنين
والمدنيين الاتراك في تلك المناطق
الجنوبيه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
العربيه
شركه ميرس كائن للنقل البحري تعرض ميناء
اسكندرون التركي لضرر هيكلي شديد بسبب
الزلزال ووقف كل العملياتفه قالت الشركه
انه تم تحويله كل الحاويات من ميناء
اسكندرون الى ميناء اي مرسين التركي
وبورسعيد المصري
[موسيقى]
وصل اليوم الى مدينه غازي عنتاب التركيه
فريق بحثي وكذلك اسعاف الماني مؤلف من 43
مسعفا للبحث عن العالقين تحت الانقاض
سيتوجه للفريق الالماني الى منطقتها تايل
للمساعده في عمليات الاغاثه هناك وغادرت
طائره الخاصه استاجرها مسعفون من مطار
كولن بالمانيا مسعفون ساهم في عمليات
اسعاف شبيهه بحوادث الزلازل مثل هايتي
واندونيسيا
لقد افادت وزاره حالات الطوارئ الروسيه
بوصول اكثر من مئه من رجال الانقاذ الروس
الى تركيا للمساعده وذكرت الوزاره ان رجال
الانقاد سيتجهون الى واحده من اكثر
المناطق تضررا وهي كهرمان مرعش في جنوب
شرق تركيا وسيعملون على مدار الساعه في
عده مجموعات الوزاره اضافت بانه تم نشر
مستشفى متنقل في منطقه الطوارئ من جهتها
قالت وسائل اعلام صينيه ستقدم دفعه اولى
قدرها خمسه ملايين الف دولار كمساعدات
طارئه لجهود الاغاثه في تركيا بعد الزلزال
الكبير الذي ضرب البلاد هذا الاسبوع
واضافت بان الصليب الاحمر الصيني سيقدم
مساعدات طارئه قيمتها 200 الف دولار لكل
من تركيا وسوريا كما دات وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه للضغط على النظام السوري ليسمح
بدخول المساعدات الانسانيه في وقت قال
الدان رئيس بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي لدى
سوريا ان هناك حاجه لاستمرار وصول
المساعده الى المحتاجين عبر كل الخطوط
مرتاحه والحدود المفتوحه واضاف استونيسكو
بان الوقت حان لدعم جميع المتضررين
السوريين من الكارثه في جميع المناطق
السوريه مبديا استعدادا الاتحاد الاوروبي
للمساعده
وقال ايضا دبلوماسيون اوروبي للعربيه ان
سوريا لم تطلب تفعيل اليه الحمايه المدنيه
الاوروبيه لمساعده المنكوبين جراء الزلزال
العنيف مضيفا بان تفعيل اليه الحمايه
المدنيه الاوروبيه يحتاج الطلبه دوله او
من الامم المتحده وهو ما لم يحدث بالنسبه
الى سوريا مؤكدا ان الاتحاد يتشاور مع
المنظمات غير الحكوميه العامله في الميدان
السوري التي تعد التقييما للوضع وسبل
المساعده
من اسطنبول ينضم الينا الدكتور مهند حافظ
فقلول اكاديمي والباحث السياسي سيد مهند
مرحبا بك معنا في هذه التغطيه يعني عندما
تطالب وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه بالضغط
على النظام السوري وهناك مطالبات كذلك من
منظمه الصحه العالميه بالضغط على النظامين
السوري والروسي لايصال هذه المساعدات هنا
الى اي مدى يمكن للنزاعات الاقليميه
والخلافات اصلا الموجوده في الاراضي
السوريه ان تقف عائقا امام تقديم المساعده
الانسانيه العاجله الان للمتضررين في
المناطق السوريه المنكوبه بشكل عام
استاذ خالد وجميع المشاهدين واشكرك على
هذا السؤال الذي يعني يمص الموقف وصلب
المشكله بشكل مباشر بالفعل يعني النزاعات
السياسيه او الحسابات السياسيه حتى المارب
والاهداف السياسيه من يدفع ثمنها هي
الانسانيه هي تلك الارواح البريئه المدنيه
وبالتالي لا يبدو اننا
نزول في دائره مفرغه من الحوارات مع
النظام السوري بشكل عام او حتى مع الجانب
الروسي لماذا لان هناك منطق لديهم بان
النظام السوري هو شرعي طيب لماذا لا يطالب
الامم المتحده لماذا لا يطالب
بالاغاثات لهؤلاء المنكوبين الامر اكبر من
الاهداف السياسيه ان كان هناك بقيه باقيه
من
انسانيه ولكن يبدو ان الامر سوف يبقى على
ما هو عليه
الا اللهم اذا كان هناك بعض الامدادات او
المعونات القادمه من بعض الدول العربيه
لمساعده
المنكوبين تحت الانقاض في البقعه
الجغرافيه من سوريا التي هي تحت سيطره
النظام العمر يجب يعني دوليه
انسانيه اقليميه سميه اوصفه كما شئت ولكن
بالفعل الذي حدث لم لم تشهدوا المنطقه لم
يشهده التاريخ عندما يعلن الرئيس اردوغان
ان ثلاثه اشهر يعلن عشر محافظات تركيه
بانها منكوبه
اذا نحن في مرحله ومنعطف جديد وخطير جدا
لذلك هناك تقاعس حقيقي وكبير من المجتمع
الدولي في توصيل تلك على المساعدات فضلا
عن المشكله الام الاساسيه في الجانب
السوري هناك تكلمت عن عدم وجود
تقديم للملف الانساني على الملفات
والاهداف لكن على منطقه المسؤوليه هنا
دكتور مهند
المسؤوليه بشكل مباشر تقع على النظام
السوري الذي المفترض ان يكون هو من يقوم
بما يجب ان يقوم به في حمايه او انقاذ
المدنيين الذين هم تحت الانقاب لماذا لا
يطالب المتحده بمساعده يعني هذا سؤال بدا
يعني هل لديه النظام السوري اعاني هنا هل
لديه القدرات والامكانيات
لانقاذ منهم تحت الانقاض اذا كانت تركيا
بخبراتها الطويله مع الزلازل تقف اليوم
بموقف ضعيف بسبب ان الحجر الكارثه اكبر
بكثير من امكانيه اي دوله في العالم فما
بالك بنظام متهالك لا يملك لا الخبره في
التعامل مع الزلازل لا يملك الاليات او
المعدات للتعامل مع وانتشال او انقاذ من
هم تحت الانقاض الهدف المعرب السياسي هو
الذي يطغى في الموقف او في الجانب السوري
وهذا ما يدفع ثمنه من المدنيون في المحصله
وبنتظر الى تاريخ
العقد الاخير في سوريا لا يهم بطبيعه
الحال النظام السوري المدني لا يهمهم لا
يهمه المدنيين يهمه ان يبقى هو في
زياده الحكم وان يبقى لكن
حتى من النظام السوري الان يعني هو يقول
او يناشد العالم بان يرفع عنه الحصار حتى
تصل هذه المساعدات قبل قليل كنت استمع
كذلك الى رئيس منظمه الهلال الاحمر السوري
او الدفاع المدني السوري هو كذلك يقول
بانه مستعدون لايصال المساعدات
للمناطق الاخرى وربما هو يقصد بالمناطق
الاخرى غير الخاضعه ربما لسيطره النظام
حلب ادلب غيرها من المناطق فبالتالي يعني
حتى النظام السوري هو في ازمه الان الحصار
عليه كما يقول ما رايه
هو في ازمه ولكنه يكابر يعني عندما يستغيث
بشكل عام وانه يطالب الدعم من كل الاطراف
هذه استغاثه عامه لماذا لا يتقدم بطلب
رسمي مباشر من حكومه تفترض انها
الارواح الناس هناك الى الامم المتحده
وبالتالي تكون هناك المنظمات الانسانيه
والاغاثيه وتقوم كما كانت هناك معونات
مقدمه الى الجانب التركي تذهب هذه
المعونات عبر جسر جوي
لانتشال من هم تحت الانقاض وانقاذ من بقي
منهم اصلا من الاحياء يعني كلما مرت ساعه
كلما كان الثمن باهظ ويدفع بالارواح ولكن
هذا التقاعس وهذا
الاستكبار في انه لا يقدم طلبا رسميا من
دوله الى الامم المتحده يعني الموقف غير
مفهوم بشكل عجيب اذا كانت المتحده من يمثل
الدوله السوريه هو هذا النظام السوري اذا
من المنطق وان لديه ممثلا في الامم
المتحده لماذا لا يقوم بطلب رسمي لانقاذ
من يمكن انقاذهم الوضع ماساوي جدا يعني
اذا كان الوضع في تركيا
لفك الحصار كما قالوا لايصال المساعدات
المناشدات من الدول لتقديم الدعم المطلوب
يعني لماذا لابد من طلب رسمي في هذه
الحاله هل المساله تتعلق ام انه كما قال
احد الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين بان المساله
قد تكون قانونيه يعني اكثر من اي شيء ثاني
لابد من ان تطلب سوريا من المجتمع الدولي
التفعيل اليه الحمايه المدنيه يعني
لمساعده المنكوبين هناك مساله انسانيه
وكارثه الان موجوده على الاراضي السوريه
لماذا لا يتم تجاوز كل هذه الامور نتحدث
هنا عن كل الاطراف وايصال هذه المساعدات
في ظل معاناه
الاطفال الكبار الصغار اللاجئين المشردين
من باتوا في العراء يعني بعد هذا الزلزال
لانه هناك نظام دولي وهناك قوانين دوليه
تحكم العلاقات الدوليه اذا لم تكن تركيا
قد اعلنت بانها قد وصلت الى المستوى
الرابع
في هذه الكارثه وبالتالي ناشدت عبر وزير
الداخليه بتفعيل نظام الرابع والمستوى
الرابع وتقديم او طلب الدعم من الدول
العالميه كلها
لمساعده تركيا في هذه الكارثه يعني لماذا
اذا كانت تركيا بكل
حجمها وخبراتها قامت بشكل منطقي لانها
تعرف تعرف القوانين الدوليه وتعرف كيف
تسير الامور وكيف هي
وكيف هو نظام الدولي ولكن يبدو ان نظام
سوري هو خارج هذا النظام الدولي كله وهو
بالفعل هو هكذا ما الذي يمنع من ان يقدم
طلب رسميا هذا هو القانون الدولي هذا امر
طبيعي بدعي يعني انت اليوم اذا ما اردت ان
تذهب الى المشفى بشكل عاجل عليك ان تقدم
اثباتات بانك هذا هذه هويتك الشخصيه
وتكتب استماره ومن ثم تدخل الى المكان
المخصص للعلاج هذا اذا انت كنت في وضع
يعني طبيعي وعادي فما بالك اذا كنت في وضع
كارثي مخيف يعني الامر وسوف تنجلي بعد
ايام او ربما بعد اسابيع او ربما ما بعد
اشهر ارقام مخيفه فيما يتعلق بالضحايا
التي الذين سوف نسمع عن عددهم مع الاسف في
سوريا سواء على الذين هم في النظام في
منطقه النظام السوري بشكل مباشر او حتى من
هم في مناطق المعارضه لماذا لان الدعم
مناطق المعارضه هي تركيا واليوم تركيا
الكل يعلم وضعها الكارثي المخيف في ثلاثه
اشهر نحن يعني الوضع اكبر من ماساوي هناك
تقاعس بالفعل من قبل النظام بشكل اساسي
وحتى من قبل تركيا ننظر نحن هنا الا ان
هناك
عدم عدم وببطء في التعامل الدولي مع
الكارثه التي حلت بتركيا لان الذي حصل ليس
مجرد زلزال بل هي زلازل متعدده كبيره
وبالتالي لا بد من التحرك بما يتناسب مع
حجم ثالثا اليوم بعض الدول الغربيه بشكل
خاص ان هنا اعلن يريدون التقديم المساعدات
لم يقفوا على ما يجري لم يرسل مراسلين على
الميدان ليدركوا حجم الماسات الذي تتحل
بتركيا اليوم مدينه انطاكيا على سبيل
المثال تغيرت معالمها كلها تذهب الى مدينه
انطاكيا لا تعرفها تخيل الموقف الى اين
وصل هنا هناك خطه اليوم سوف تدرس في داخل
التركي لدى الحكومه باخلاء مدن من ساكنها
على المطلق لان هناك ارتدادات واهتزازات
وبحكم العلماء الجيولوجيون وبتنسيق مع
الحكومه التركيه سوف يخلون مدن بالكامل
تخيل الموقف الى مدى بشاعته ومدى صعوبته
دكتور تبقى معي ساعود اليك
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله
اكبر ما شاء الله
الى رفع القيود المفروضه على سوريا للسماح
بوصول المساعدات لغتي وقال رئيس منظمه
الهلال الاحمر السوري خالد حبوباتي اننا
نتائج الزلزال الذي شهدته سوريا كارثيه
وهناك حاجه ماسه لمعدات ثقيله وسيارات
اسعاف واطفاء لتتمكن المنظمه من مواصله
عمليات الانقاذ وازاله الانقاض
من دمشق ضم الينا المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان حزم
سيد عدنان مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه ما
هو تقييمكم اولا في الصليب الاحمر لحجم
الدمار الذي خلفه هذا الزلزال في المناطق
السوريه المنكوبه
اعتقد ما عرفته في تقريركم او ماذا
تتناوله القنوات من صور
لحجم هذا
الزلزال واثره الكارثيه قد يكون هو فقط
جزء بسيط من الواقع الماساوي الكارثي الذي
خلف ظهره خلفه هذا
الزلزال طبعا نحن في اللجنه الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر منذ الساعه الاولى متواصلين
مع شريكنا الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري في
تقديم العون الانساني والاغاثه
والطبي
خلال هذه حتى هذه اللحظه هناك تنسيق مع
شركائنا بالعمل الانساني في سوريا لتقديم
المزيد وكذلك
للتخفيف من معاناه المتضررين من هذه
الكارثه التي اضافت الى وجعل السوريين
الما اضافيا كون سوريا كما تعرف
عانت وتعاني حتى اللحظه من من اثار صراع
لمده 12 عام
اثر كثيرا على جوانب الحيه بشكل عام حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك الارقام مرعبه عندما
تتكلم اليوم عن 15 مليون سوري بحاجه
لمساعدات عندما تتكلم ان 50% من المنشات
الصحيه لا تعمل هذه الارقام وغيرها من
الارقام التي تسمعونها او هذه المشاهد
الذي تعرضونها تعكس الواقع الماساوي
والكارثه في سوريا ياتي الزلزال ليضيف
اوجاعا وماساه اخرى للشعب
اتاثر بشكل كبير في مختلف حياته اليوميه
في ظل هذه الظروف كيف تسير عمليات الانقاذ
والمساعده للمنكوبي
طبعا على مدار الساعه هناك فرق الهلال
الاحمر العربي السوري وكذلك
غيري من الدفاع المدني وغيرهم يقومون
بانتشال الجثث من تحت الانقاذ وانقاذ من
يمكن انقاذهم من تحت الركام الى جانب ان
هناك مراكز وتم انشاء في المناطق المنكوبه
نحن دورنا باللهجه الدولي الاحمر قمنا
بالتزويد بعض المستشفيات بالمواد الجراحيه
وكذلك المواد الاغاثيه والغذائيه لتلك
المراكز الايوائيه
ماذا تحتاج الان هذه المناطق يعني طبيعه
هذه المساعدات التي تحتاجها
وخاصه هناك الكثير من الدول التي اعلنت عن
حزم من المساعدات سترسلها الى تركيا
وسوريا كيف سيتم
طبعا مثل هذه المبادره التي قمت بها
الدول في تقديم العون العاجل لسوريا هي
هي قد تخفف من المعاناه ونتمنى ان تتواصل
كذلك المزيد من من الدعم وخاصه في مجال
رفع الانقاب
وايجاد وايجاد
وايجاد حلول او تدخلات انسانيه تخفف من
المعاناه ليس فقط في هذه الكارثه ولكن
نتكلم عن الماسه الماساه الوضع السوري
بشكل عام
هل هناك مساعدات يعني الدوليه من اي طرف
كان وصلت الان او هل هناك اي اتصالات تجري
مع ايات اي منظمات ايضا اخرى الدوله دوليه
مستعده لتقديم اي نوع من المساعده
طبعا في بالمجمل في العمل الانساني او
الاغاثه هناك عوائق مختلفه سواء كانت
الجانب الامني او كذلك طبيعه المناطق
وخاصه عندما يكون هناك سواء كان هناك
زلازل او فيضانات هناك مع ذلك كمنظمه
انسانيه نعمل على ايجاد حدود في اصابه تلك
المساعدات ولكن ندعو الان الى ان يكون
هناك تحشيد حقيقي
لمعالجه تداعيات هذا الزلزال واثره
السلبيه والكارثيه على المناطق التي تاثرت
في سوريا وان يكون هناك استجابه مستدامه
للحاله الانسانيه في سوريا يعني انتم
عندما تتواصلون مع هذه الدول او مع
الهيئات والمنظمات الدوليه ماذا يقولون
لكم يعني حتى يعني ماذا يعيقهم عن ايصال
مساعداتهم يعني لكل الان يتحدث عن يعني
ضروره ايصال هذه المساعدات ضروره
المسائل الانسانيه المعاناه للاهالي للناس
الناجحين المشردين الان في المناطق
السوريه بشكل عام المنكوبه ولكن ما الذي
يمنع هذه الهيئات فعليا من وصول مساعداتها
سيداتنا ماذا يقولون
كمنظمه انسانيه
دول العالم خاصه اثناء النزاعات مثل هذه
الخارجيه مع الاسف مع الاسف كما تتابعون
لدينا مشكله تقنيه في وصول الصوت سنعود
اليه حال
سنعود اليه هل تمكنا من اصلاح هذا الخلل
نذكر مجددا بالاخبار العاجله حيث قالت
كبيره مسؤولي مكتب الطوارئ في منظمه الصحه
العالميه
عدد المتضررين بالزلزال المدمر الذي اودى
بحياه الالاف في تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى
ثلاثه وعشرين مليون مضيفه
بان او امام اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده ان
من بين المتضررين نحو خمسه ملايين في حاله
ضعف
كما اعلنت رئاسه المصريه ان الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي تواصل هاتفيا مع نظيره
السوري بشار الاسد مؤكدا على تقديم كافه
اوجه العون والمساعده الاغاثيه لسوريا اثر
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
ونعيد التذكير بما شددت عليه وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا باي بروك
بضروره ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المناطق المنكوبه الزلزال في سوريا
وممارسه الضغط على النظام السوري للتعاون
مع الجهات الدوليه بهدف اغاثه المنكوبين
من اسطنبول نعود الى ضيفنا الدكتور مهند
حافظ اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
دكتور مهند استمعت الى ما قاله ممثل
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في في سوريا
حول الموقف الان اي تعليق على ما ذكره
يعني محاولات كلها مناشدات
وتصريحات على الواقع الامر لا يتغير يعني
المشكله هو هذا الفارق ما بين المناشدات
العامه وهو بحكم اختصاصهم يناشد وهو هذا
امر طبيعي ولكن ما الذي سوف يتحرك على ارض
الواقع لا شيء يبدو لي انه ربما من المفيد
جدا اذا ما كان صوت المختصين من علماء
الجيولوجيا ان اذا ما اعلوا صوتهم
وتمت ربما ربما هذا مجرد اقتراح كتابه
عريضه من عده علماء جيولوجيين يقولون
ويناشدون الدول الفاعله والعالميه وصاحبه
القدره على تقديم الدعم الحقيقي ربما اذا
ما يعني وضعوه في الصوره الكامله
والحقيقيه وان هذه هي سلسله الزلازل وليس
الزلزالا واحدا وربما
تضرب مناطق اخرى في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط نحن لا نتكلم عن الصحيفه
العربيه والصحيفه الاوراسيه اذا نحن نتكلم
عن بقعه جغرافيه طويله ليست فقط مختصره في
تركيا او سوريا بل تشمل لبنان فلسطين
اصولا الى
اليونان الى مصر هذه كلها ضمن هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه في منطقه الزلازل وبالتالي ربما
اذا ما كانت هذه الاصوات العلميه مرتفعه
ربما نشات تحركا سياسيا من اصحاب الراي
السياسي ممن يستطيعون بالفعل ان يحركوا ما
يجب تحريكهم يعني الدكتور مهند سريعا
مطالبات كذلك على الضغط على النظام الروسي
هل يمكننا ان تفلح اي محاولات من هذا
النوع وما هي مسؤوله نظام الروسي يعني في
ايصال هذه المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه
سريعا ايضا يعني هنا نعود ايضا الى
التشابك السياسي في الملف السوري والملف
الاوكراني
الغرب كله يقف في وجه
روسيا في اوكرانيا وبالتالي ليس هناك
تواصلا حقيقيا ما بين الشرق والغرب لان
المنفس الوحيد للجانب السوري هو روسيا
وايران وبالتالي وهما كلاهما في قوس
الازمات الدوليه وفي عقوبات دوليه مع
النظام الدولي وكذلك نظام السوري اذا لا
بد من ايجاد اليه معينه ولكن لا تعني هذا
ان نفك الحصار مثلا المفروض على سوريا
ولكن تقديم مساعدات جويه خاصه بمعدات
معينه لانقاذ من الممكن انقاذهم من تحت
الانقاض ومن ثم الاستمرار بعد ان يعني وضع
تنتهي هذه او التداعيات هذا الزلزال
المرعب نذهب ونعود الى المربع الاول
الخلافات السياسيه وما
شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول الدكتور مهند
حافظ السياسي
والى مدينه هاتايا التركيه حيث عبر صراخ
وخوف طفله اثناء انقاذها من تحت انقاذ احد
البنايات عبر عن حجم الكارثه فكانت
والدتها اول من خطرت في بالها
[موسيقى]
نعود الى دمشق الى المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان
حزام سيد عدنان
ماذا عن الاوضاع في مناطق سوريه مثل حمامه
الادلب مثل حلب وغيرها هل هناك من صوره
وصلت لكم هل هناك ايضا اي تواصل مع الفرق
التي تقوم بمحاولات الانقاذ واسعاف
الناجين او انتشال يعني العالقين
طبعا
الكارثه هذه لهذا الزلزال وكذلك الازمه
السوريه هي لم تؤثر على منطقه جغرافيه
واحده فقط في سوريا ولكن هي عمه الجغرافيا
السوريه باكملها وجميع السوريين سواء
بالشمال او الشرق او الغرب ما يهمنا هو
الان ان يكون هناك في ان يكون هناك
استجابه عاجله لتخفيف من المعاناه وان
يكون هناك
دعم حقيقي من اجل معالجه اثار اكثر من 12
عاما من النزاع والصراع وان يكون هناك عدم
تاسيس لملف الانساني كون ذلك لا يصب
بمصلحه السوريين بشكل عام
طيب ما هي اهم الان المساعدات المطلوبه في
هذا الوقت تحديدا
اهم المساعده هي الاغافيه والطبيه كون
هناك الالاف من الجرحى الذين
تضرروا من هذا الزلزال وكذلك الان هناك
مئه العوائل التي فقدت منازلها الان اصبحت
تنضم الى النازحين كما تعلم ان هناك في
سوريا حتى الان سبعه مليون سوري للاسف
الشديد الوضع الانساني كنا نقول عنهما
ولكن بهذه الكارثه اصبح كارثه بما تعنيه
الكلمه من معنى نتمنى ان يكون هناك صدى
حقيقي من المجتمع الدولي الى تقديم المزيد
من الدعم وان يكون هناك تسهيل للعمل
الانساني سواء في اي منطقه بالنسبه للدول
التي عرضت تقديم مساعداتها لسوريا هل تم
التواصل مع اي منها او يجري هذا التواصل
الان هل من النتائج يمكن الحديث عنها
اعتقد التحشيد الانساني سواء كان من اي من
دول او منظمات هو ويصب فيها في خانه
التخفيف من معاناه السوريين بالنسبه لنا
في اللجنه الدولي الصليب الاحمر لنا
الياتنا في التواصل مع الدول والمانحين في
الحصول على الدعم اللازم ولكن من خلالكم
ندعو ان يكون هناك اهتمام اكبر خاصه وان
الازمه السوريه او الوضع الانساني في
سوريا ظل منسيا نتمنى ان يكون هنا ان تكون
هذه اللحظه الماساويه للاسف الشديد هي
تذكير للمجتمع الدولي ان هناك ازمه سوريا
ازمه اسمها سوريا هناك ملايين السوريين
اليوم يعانون بتاع داعيات كما قلت لك
الصراع ووضع اقتصادي سيء اثر على جميع
مناحي الحياه حتى اللحظه هناك اسد لا
تستطيع توفير الغذاء
لدع وجبه واحده باليوم هناك وضع غير غير
ما يخص ما يخص من تداعيه هذا الزلزال
للاسف الشديد الذي اضاف لاوجاع السوريين
المزيد شكرا جزيلا لك من دمشق المتحدث
باسم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في
سوريا عدنا حزم نعيد التذكير بالاخبار
العاجله التي نشاهدها على الشاشه الصليب
الاحمر للعربيه قال ان هناك 15 مليون سوري
هم في حاجه لمساعدات قبل الزلزال والان
الوضع اسوا بكثير ونطالب بالمزيد من الدعم
لجهود
الانقاذ في سوريا وان هناك ارتفاعا
متسارعا لعدد الضحايا الزلزال
الخوض البيضاء تحذر من نفاد الوقت بسبب
ضعف الامكانات في المناطق المنكوبه في
شمال سوريا
ربما الان
نحاول استيضاح الصوره بشكل اكبر من خلال
ضيفنا الذي ينضم الينا الان من الحدود
السوريه التركيه ابراهيم
الصحفي سيد ابراهيم اهلا بك من ادلب
تحديدا كيف هي صوره الاوضاع الان سيد
ابراهيم اهلا وسهلا بك وبجميع المشاهدين
من جديد ارتفعت حصيله الوفيات لتصل الى
900 شخص كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم قبل ساعه
ونصف ساعتين كان العدد واتمان ميه وعشره
ولكن الان اصبح 900 شخص لك وحتفه قامت فرق
الدفاع المدني بانتشال جثث القتلى او
المتوفين من تحت الانقاض فيما ارتفعت
حصيله المصابين لتصل الى 2300 شخص مصاب
كما نقلهم على مدار منذ لحظه بدايه
الزلزال الى هذه اللحظه الى نقاط الطبيه
والمستشفيات من اجل تلقي العلاج حقيقه منذ
قليل لوحظ ان هناك بعض من السيارات
المدنيه التي تعود الى داخل مدينه ادلب من
اجل الحصول على بعض الامثله على بعض
المواد الاوليه ثم محاوله الخروج خارج
المدينه لا يزال هناك تخوف قبل المدنيين
بما من ردات اهتزازيه او من زلزال اخر
خاصه ان المنطقه او منطقه شمال شرق سوريا
تفتقد لهيئه اداره الزلازل او للمعلومات
الرسميه لذلك يتم استقاء المعلومات
الرسميه من الامكان من تركيا او عبره
القنوات الرسميه عبره متحدثين لذلك ما
يزال عمليه التخوف جل هؤلاء المدنيين
المتواجدين نحن نتحدث عن عمق اكثر من 30
كيلو متر في على الحدود السوريه التركيه
متواجدين في العراء عشرات الالاف منهم من
الاطفال والنساء الذين يفضلون البقاء
حاليا في العراء او البحث عن ماوى قريب من
المنشات السكنيه بسبب صعوبه الوصول باتجاه
الشمال السوري مع انقطاع بعض الطرق بسبب
تراكم الثلوج من العاصفه الثلجيه السابقه
وحتى استمرار العاصفه المطريه الحاليه مما
صعب عمليه فتح الطرق بالنسبه للمدني
للتنقل هناك فقط بعض الطرق الوعره
التي تستخدمها السيارات التي تقل المصابين
الذين يتم استخراجهم من تحت الانقاض من
داخل العمق السوري باتجاه المنطقه
الحدوديه من اجل تلقي العلاج لان
المستشفيات المتمركزه على الحدود السوريه
التركيه او حتى مشفى عفرين العسكري هم
اكثر ان كانهم او الافضل حاليا على مستوى
الطبابه بالنسبه للمعدات وحتى بالنسبه
للمخزون الطبي الذي الذي تستخدمه
المستشفيات هناك
يعني هؤلاء النازحون او المشردون
الذين فقدوا ربما منازلهم التي دمرت
جراء هذا الزلزال كيف قدوا ليلتهم سيد
ابراهيم من يقوم ايضا بمهام الانقاذ
المساعده لهم تامين احتياجاتهم كذلك مساله
انتشال ربما العالقين من تحتها الانقاذ
هذه المباني
دعنا نبدا بمن بقي على قيد الحياه وكيف
قضى ليله الامس واين قضاها هنا العديد من
المدينه تحدثت عن عشرات الالاف من من قضوا
الليله في العراء يفتقدون الى ابسط مقومات
التدفئه كانوا يعانون قرص البرد على
العوده باتجاه المنازل خشيه من زلزال اخر
خصوصا ان المنازل اصبحت مصدعه قابله
لانهيار في اي لحظه من هزه ارتداديه في
حال كانت قويه او كافيه لتدمير المنازل
هناك فئه من المدنيين ايضا لجوا الى
المواصلات وعربات النقل والعربات التي
انتشرت اما بالساحات البعيده عن الاغنياء
وحتى على الطرق الواصله ما بين المدن
والقرى باتجاه الشمال السوري وكانت محطه
مؤقته من اجل الحصول على القليل من الدفا
الى الاطفال في تلك المرحله هناك قسم من
المدنيين ايضا اتجه باتجاه المخيمات على
عشوائيه الموجوده بالاراضي الزراعيهم
يجدون ايضا بعض الدفن في بعض الخيام هناك
استقبالهم من قبل ناجحين ده او نازحين
داخليا ضمن المخيمات العشوائيه من حالفه
الحظ وكان قريبا من المنطقه الشماليه من
سوريا اي قريب من الحدود السوريه التركيه
وصل الى التجمع مخيمات اضمه والمخيمات
المحيطه بها ليكون علاجا عند لاجئ اخر
لديه خيمه وبعض المؤولات الحياه الذين
تقاسموا حقيقه
المواد الموجوده من اجل انقضاء ليله امس
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر كانت هناك محاوله
فقط للعوده لاخذ بعض الاغذيه او بعض
الملابس لان الحاله قبل بيوم كان هناك
عمليه خروج بشكل خروج خروج مستعجل اي
الجميع خرج فقط بما يرتديه من ملابس ولذلك
كان هناك نقص بالافرشه وايضا ببعض ادوات
التدفئه او حتى على الاغذيه من اجل الحصول
على التدفئه عوده عاد بعضهم منهم ولكن لا
يملك اجراء الكثير منهم ليعلم ان منزله قد
تهدم واصبح غير السكن والاغراض او الادوات
التي كان يحتاجها اصبحت تحت الركام لا
يمكن استخدامه هنا استدعى تدخل المنظمات
الانسانيه العامه الى داخل الاراضي
السوريه التي قامت بالعمل على محورين او
ضمن استطاعتها الاولى هي توزيع بعض
المساعدات داخل المخيمات ثم على المحور
الثاني
ارسال بعض المساعدات باتجاه المدنيين
الذين اباتوا بالشوارع وعلى الطرق العامه
بالعربات او حتى
بالعناصر هذه المساعدات
لم تصل هذه المساعدات كانت منذ الاساس
داخل الاراضية لكن لا يمكن الحديث عن اي
مساعدات جديده من اي جهه كانت او منظمه او
هيئه هذه اللحظه انقطاع اكثر من مع مضى
اكثر من 30 ساعه على الزلزال الاول او على
الفاجعه والكارثه لم يصل اي شيء الى داخل
الحدود السوريه التركيه امن خارج سوريا
جميع المساعدات كانت من المستودعات او من
المنظمات والمؤسسات العامله في المجال
الانساني داخل الاراضي هل جرت اي اتصالات
من اي جهه كانت معكم او مع اي طرف كان
داخل هذه المناطق المنكوبه ابراهيم لم يتم
رصد اي اتصال مباشر ما بين من جهات
المانحه والجهات العامله داخل الاراضي
السوريه والجميع شاهد ان هناك العديد من
المناشدات من داخل اعراض السوريه لامداد
فرق الدفاع المدني والمتطوعين بالمزيد من
الاليات او المعدات التي تساعدهم على
الاسراع ومحاربه الوقت في انقاذ العالقين
تحت الانقاظ ايضا من جهه ثانيه المنظمات
العامله بالشهاده الانسان التي توحدت ضمن
بيان واحد وارسلته الى المانحين من اجل
المس
والاستعجال في ارسال مساعدات انسانيه
اوليه طارئه للمدنيين المتضررين من
الزلزال المتواجدين في العراء او حتى
الذين قدموا الى الحدود السوريه التركيه
حتى الان لم يتم الاستجابه لهذا الامر
هناك طبعا فقد تكون قد تعود لعده عوامل
منها انقطاع الطرق باتجاه الاراضي السوريه
التركيه المؤديه من تركيا ايضا عدم ثقه
الممولين بنظام اسد من اجل تمرير هذه
المساعدات لذلك التفكير الان وجب التفكير
بحلول سريعه او بحلول منطقيه كانشاء جسر
جوي شكرا جزيلا لك ابراهيم الادلبي الصحفي
من الحدود السوريه التركيه